[موسيقى]
الحصان
كاس العالم قطر 2022 دخلت مراحل الحسن في
اطار اليوم الثاني من مباريات الدوره
السنغال منتخب انجلترا في استاد البيت في
مدينه الخور
بعيدا عن الرياضه تاتينا هذه الصور من
موسكو قبل ساعه من دخول حزمه جديده من
العقوبات الاوروبيه على روسيا حيز التنفيذ
في وقت تحذر فيه السلطات روسيه من اضطراب
اسواق الطاقه
اماران فتصلنا منها هذه الصور بعد ساعات
من اعلان المدعي العام الايراني وقف الجهه
المعنيه عمل شرطه الاخلاق في البلاد
في مواضيع الحصاد
[موسيقى]
الطاقه
وتنسيقا عسكري الايراني
قبل ساعات من بدء فرد اوروبا سقفا لسعر
نفط روسيا لحرمانها من تمويل حربها موسكو
تلوح بخفض الانتاج وتثير مخاوف من احتمال
اضطراب سوق الطاقه ودول تحالف اوبيك بلاست
تقرر الالقاء على حصص انتاجها
بعد ثلاثه اشهر من الاحتجاجات قرار من
المدعي العام الايراني بوقف عمل شرطه
الاخلاق وتاكيد على ان البرلمان والمجلس
الاعلى للثوره الثقافيه يبحثان مساله
الحجاب وسيعللان نتائج خلال اسبوعين عبد
الله هيان يتهم دول غربيه بتاجيج
الاحتجاجات للضغط على بلاده
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان المدعي العام
الايراني ان الجهات التي انشات شرطه
الاخلاق اتخذت قرارا بوقف عمل المنظومه في
هذه المرحله مجهودا تبذر لايجاد حل مدروس
والتعامل مع ظاهره عدم رعايه الحجاب التي
ازعجت الجميع بحسب تعبيره
باستطلاع رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع وطرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم الى ما يمهد
قرار السلطات الايرانيه وقف عمل شرطه
الاخلاق
33% توقعوا حلل الجهاز بالكامل بينما توقع
35% عودته للعمل لاحقا وقال 32% من الخطوه
تمهيد لاعاده تاطير عملي شرطه الاخلاق
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروح ان على منصه
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوريه
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
12:00 وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات
المونديال التي ترصد بالخبر والتحليل
مباريات كاس العالم قطر 20022
[موسيقى]
منخر كيف بالشمال الشرقي الى دنيا
جنوبا نزل اكثر من 500 بلده اوكرانيه بدون
كهرباء تقول وزاره الداخليه الاوكرانيه ان
السبب هو ضربات روسيه الحقت في الاسابيع
الاخيره اضرارا كبيره بشبكه الكهرباء
الوطني
500 وسبع بلدات في اوكرانيا دون كهرباء
وفقا يفكيني مين النائب الاول لوزير
الداخليه الاوكراني فان الاستهداف الروسيه
المتواصله لمحطات الطاقه جعل من طاقه
كخاركيز في صداره المناطق المتضرره وان
112 قريه فيها باتت معزوله تليها منطقه
دونيتك وخرسون حيث تضررت اكثر من 90 قريه
فضلا عن اثتين و80 قريه في نيكولايف و76
تتواصلوا دعوات الحكوميه للصمود امام شتاء
تتسارع خطواته بدا القصف الروسي المنتظم
للبنيه التحتيه الحيويه في اوكرانيا منذ
العاشر من اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي بعد
يومين من قصف جسر القرم وبالتالي تعطي
موسكو الحق لنفسها في استهداف البنا
التحتيه الاوكرانيه
ابرز محطات الطاقه المتضرره هي زاباروجيا
التي تتبادل اوكرانيا وروسيا الاتهامات
باستهدافها وقالت الامم المتحده في ال 23
من نوفمبر الماضي ان محطه دار نيتسكا
الحراريه للطاقه في كيف تعرضت للقصف ما
حرم منطقه تكييف باكملها من الكهرباء وبقي
ما يقرب من ثلاثه ملايين انسان في العاصمه
دون مياه انجاريه كما تعرضت محطه توليد
الكهرباء لدزهند منطقه القصف ودمرت
الضربات الروسيه البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
كريم شوك والبيف واديسه
كانت كيف تستهدف رفع حصه الطاقه النظيفه
الى 25 في المئه بحلول عام 2030 لكنها
وعلى وقع الضربات الروسيه اعلنت فقد نحو
90% من منطقه الرياح و 50% من الطاقه
الشمسيه وكان رئيس مجلس الدوم الروسي
فياتشي سلاف فولدين قد اعلن في اكتوبر
الماضي تضرر اكثر من 70 منشاه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا الامر الذي افقد البلاد نصف
الطاقه المولده
في التفاصيل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها شنت مسمته هجوما ناجحا في محور
بخموت شرقيه اوكرانيا اسفر عن مقتل يكثر
من 50 جنديا اوكرانيا وتدمير ست اليات
عسكريه اوكرانيه ومخازن النفط في خارف كما
تعرضت احياء في مدينه دونياسك لقصف مدفعين
اوكراني وقالت السلطات والمحليه ان القذف
خلف اربعه
الجيش الاوكراني انه اوقع قتلى وجرحى في
صفوف الجنود الروس بقصد على اليوتيوب في
مقاطعه جنوبيه البلاد واكد الجيش
الاوكراني واستمرار القصف الروسي على
مقاطعه خرسون جنوبا كما اشارت السلطات
الاوكرانيه الى تعرض عمومي
لقصف الروسي المدفعيه طيله الساعات
الماضيه
وصلت معدات عسكريه امريكيه الى ميناء في
بولندا في ايطاليا برنامج لاعاده انتشار
المعدات والقوات التابعه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي وتشكل هذه المعدات جزءا من حوالي
2400 مركبه وصلت الى بولندا واليونان خلال
الشهر الماضي من فرقه المشاهده الاولى
التابعه للجيش الامريكي
نقل موقعه
الامريكيه
بشان ايران عالم ملفات اساسيه منها
امتدادات الاسلحه الى روسيا بدلا من
المحادثات المتوقفه لاحياء الاتفاق النووي
حديث يتزامنوا مع لقاء روسي ايراني عسكريا
في طهران جمع نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي
الكسندر فونين وقائد الاركان الايرانيه
اللواء محمد باقري في اطار اجتماع رابع
للجنه المشتركه للتعاون العسكري هذا واكد
على ضروره ترسيخ التعاون الايراني والروسي
في اطار الاهداف والمصالح الوطنيه لكل
الطرفين من اجل احلال السلام والاستقرار
في المنطقه على حد تعبير
يضمه الينا من موسكو السيد فرحات براغيموف
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي ومنكير السيد
تيموفي ميلوفانوف مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
مرحبا بكما سيد فرهاد ابدا معك الى ماذا
يؤشر هذا الجمود في الجبهات سواء في
الجنوب او في الشرق
بطوله كره القدم ونحن في موسكو نشاهد هذه
البطوله وهذا شيء رائع ان نشهده واتمنى
لكم ان النجاح
الامر الثاني اريد ان اقول التالي فعلا
نحن نرى ان هناك في عمليه العسكريه في
مختلف الجهاد وهذا مؤقت فقط اريد ان اؤكد
لكم هنا ان في اقرب وقت سوف يكون هناك
هجمات جديده يوجد بعض الامراء المعلقه
ولكن روسيا لن تتوقف عن النجاح في هذه
العمليه العسكريه منذ البدايه
وبعض المناطق السكانيه تعود الى سيطره وقت
العسكريه الروسيه ويجب ان نقول هنا انه
فعلا اوكرانيا ونظام كيف
يحصلون على اسلحه جديده من نيته
ويجمعون القوات ليهاجموننا ولكن روسيا
تقوم بكل ما لديها حتى لا تسمح بهذا
بالحدود وسوف نرى نجاح جديد من قبل القوات
الروسيه في الدنبر
في الجبهات هناك قراءه للمخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيه تقول بان هذا الجمود ربما
سيتطور اكثر الى تراجع حتى في حته همم
القتال في الاشهر المقبله مع دخول فصل
الشتاء وايضا عوامل اخرى تتعلق بالحسابات
الداخليه في اوكرانيا على صعيد القتال هل
هل روسيا نفس التصور والقراءه حول الاشهر
المقبله ووضع الجبهات
روشه تعتقد ان اهم شيء هو
النجاح في العمليات والاهداف الموضوع ليس
لدينا اي فرق هل هذا شتاء او صيف بالنسبه
لنا اهم شيء هو تحرير الاراضي من النازيه
وبالنسبه لنا اهم شيء ان يتنفس الشعب
الحريه واما بالنسبه للمخابرات الامريكيه
قالوا اننا سوف نشتغل قبل موسم الشتاء
واننا سوف ينتهي مخذون الصواريخ
لدينا لذلك انصحكم بعدم تصديق المخابرات
الامريكيه لان اغلب قراءاتهم هي مزيفه طيب
سريعا برزت تصريحات لرئيس الفرنسي يتحدث
عن ضمانات امنيه لروسيا مقابل
التفاوض لحل النساء في اوكرانيا كيف
يمكنني موسكو ان تتعامل مع هذه التصريحات
وهي كانت تطالب دائما
بضمانات امنيه
كلمات
السيد
نحن لا نصدق اي من القيادات الاوروبيه
لاننا نعلم الى ماذا يؤدي هذا ولقد نادينا
القيادات الاوروبيه وبما فيها ماكرون ان
يقوم احد
باعاده التوازن في المنطقه ولم يقوم احد
منهم باي شيء وقمنا بكل ما لدينا حتى نقل
لهذا لم ينشط الينا احد اما الان يحاول
مقرون ان يعرض لنا بعض الضمانات الامنيه
ايه ما هذه الضمانات اذا
كانت القصف يستمر في المناطق في الشرق في
زمولوجيا في الدم بس نحن نرى كلمات فارغه
ولا نراعي افعال لذلك نحن لا نصدق اي
قياده اوروبيه لانهم ليس لديهم اي قدره
لاعاده التوازن في المنطقه لذلك قولهم
انهم سوف يضمنون لنا الامن نحن نفهم اننا
شكرا ان دون ان يكسبوا بعض الوضع ثم
يكتبوا بعض الوقت ثم يعود للقذف شكرا
فرهاد ابراجيموف في موسكو سيد ميلوفانوف
في اكياس في وقت تسعى القوات الاوكرانيه
للحصول على مزيد من الاراضي التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا والقوات المواليه لها شرقا
وجنوبا يبرز تقييم للمخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيه تحدث عن تراجع بوتيره القتال في
الجبهات في الاشهر المقبله ماذا تفهمون من
هذه التقييم المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه
امس
يكونوا صحيحا لكننا راينا ان روسيا قد
اجتاح توك رانيا في فتره الشتاء في شهر
فبراير وكان هذا الجزء الاقصى من الحرب
واذا
نعرف انه خلال الشتاء بالرغم من البرد قد
يكون هناك معارك محتدمه طيب ايضا فيما
يتعلق بمطرحه الرئيس الفرنسي
بما يتعلق بتقديم ضمانات لروسيا مقابل
العوده لطاوله المفاوضات لانهاء الصراع
وقال الرئيس مكروبي انه سيتحدث
للرئيسكي كيف يمكن ان تتعامل
السلطات في اوكرانيا مع طرح كندا
رشاشون التي سيطرت عليها
ولم تسيطر على كيف وبالتالي نرى ان الجيش
الاوكراني يسيطر ويتصدر الجيش الروسي
سيكون على روسيا في مرحله معينه ان تغادر
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وحين ذلك
ديسكارس
[موسيقى]
اي حروف المستقبل واعتقد ان الجميع مرحب
به يمكن للرئيس الفرنسي ماكرو اننقل ذلك
لاي قائد سياسي او رئيس اخر وسيكون هذا
ممتازه
سلبي تجاه مطرحها الرئيس
الاعتبار قبل فتره مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي
طلب الاوكرانيين بان يكونوا اكثر انفتاحا
للحوار مع روسيا
امم اوروبا
ورئيس بعيدا مؤخرا ايضا وجه سؤالا مباشره
حول المفاوضات وقال
انه من الضروريه على روسيا ان تثبت
استعدادها للحوار اي ان تسحب قوتها من
اوكرانيا وايضا ان توقفت تعذيب الناس
واتكاب جرائم الحرب وضرب المناطق المدنيه
والبلدات اذا حصل ذلك يمكن للدبلوماسيه ان
تنجح سؤال اخير سريع استفيد من وجودك معنا
بعد قليل اناقش موضوع تحديد سقف سعر النفط
الروسي كيف تنظر اوكرانيا الى تحديد 60
دولارا للبرميل الواحد
عوض الله
في السنه المقبله ستصلوا الى 170 عام
مليار دولار اصلا المقبله نعرفه تاريخيا
ان روسيا تمر في ازمه اقتصاديه اذا كانت
عائدات النفط والغاز 150 مليار واقل اذا
وصل سعر البرميل الى 30 دولار سيكون
لروسيا حافز لكي تنتج ولن يكون هناك تخفيض
للانتاج ولكن العقيدات تصل الى 100 مليار
دولار هذا يحرمها من قدرتها على تمويل
الحرب ضد المدنيين والشعب الاوكراني اذا
موقفنا هو ان هذا خطوه اولى مرحبا بها
ولكن نريد ان نرى كيف ستتبلور الامور كيف
ستاتي تبيعاتها وربما سيكون تحديدا السقف
مستقبل بعض اقصى واكثر صرامه تجاه روسيا
نوف مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني في كيس
اذا
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
بلانكن ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يستخدم فصل الشتاء سلاحا ضد المدنيين
الاوكرانيين وفي حديث مع محطه سي ان ان
وصف بلانكن ما يقوم به بوتن بالعمل الهمشي
استخدامه فصل الشتاء سلاحا عبر تعطيل
مصادر الكهرباء واغراق الشعب الاوكراني في
الظلام وتعرضهم للبرد بينما هم مقبلون على
فصل الشتاء هذا حقا سلوك همجي ونحن ندفعه
بقوه من خلال دعمنا لاوكرانيا والتاكد من
حصولهم على الدفاعات الصاروخيه التي
يحتاجونها والعمل على تزويدهم بتجهيزاتهم
التحتيه للطاقه التي يحاول بوتن تدميرها
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نصلي الضوء على
صعوبات القتال في الشتاء ونسال ضيف الحصاد
عن مسارات الحرب في الايام والاسابيع
المقبله
[موسيقى]
قررت دول تحالف اوبتك بلاس الابقاء على
حصص انتاجها المقرره منذ اكتوبر الماضي
والتي تنص على خفض الانتاج بمليونير ميلان
يوميا واكد بيان والاجتماع الافتراضي بين
الدول الاعضاء للتحالف النفطي الخطوه
اتخذت لارساء الاستقرار في السوق العالميه
وجاء القرار في اجواء يسودها عدم اليقين
وانتظار تداعيات قرار غربي بتحديده سقف
سعر الخام الروسي عند 60 دولارا يفترض ان
يدخل حيث التنفيذ يوم الاثنين او بعده وقد
حذرت موسكو من تلك الخطوه وقالت انها لن
تبيع نفطها بالسعر الذي وضعه حلفاء اكياس
لمعاقبتها
على نفس السياسه باقول اتفقا اعضاء اوبل
بلاس في اجتماعهم عبر تقنيه الفيديو على
الاستمرار في حصص انتاج النفط كما هي منذ
اكتوبر الماضي بالرغم من الحيره التي تسود
السوق والغضب الامريكيه الغربي من سياسات
التحالف النفطي
منظمه الدول المصدره للنفط وحلفائها
بقياده روسيا الذي اتخذ في اكتوبر الماضي
على خفض الانتاج بمقدار مليونير برميل في
اليوم حتى نهايه 2003
اكد بيانو اجتماعي
على القرار السابق اتخذ دعما للاسعار وجاء
فيه ان هذا الخط هو الواجب اتخذه لارسائل
الاستقرار في الاسواق
استراتيجيه التحالف النفقي وان لم تعجب
واشنطن ضروريه وفقا الدول الاعضاء عيون
الجميع ترقب الاوضاع في الصين فالبلد هو
المستورد الاول للنفط الخام في العالم وان
شيري تباطؤ اقتصادي او موجه جديده من
جائعات كورونا فيه سنعكس سلبا على الاسعار
ضرب ممثل اوبا بلوس موعدا لبعض اعضاء
التحالف في فبراير المقبل على ان يعقد
الاجتماع الوزاري الكامل في الثالثه
والرابع من يونيو العام المقبل الاجتماع
والافتراضي الذي انتهى بقرار متوقع الى حد
ما عقد في توقيت بالغ الحساسيه والتعقيدات
في الحرب الاخرى التي يشمها الغرب بقياده
الولايات المتحده على روسيا قرروا الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا فرض
السقف على سعر النفط الخام الروسي
المنقولي بحرا عند الستين دولارا سيدخل
حيز التنفيذ الاثنين او بعد ذلك رده موسكو
على هذا الاجراء العقاب بالقول انها
لمتابعه نطقها بهذا السعر
واوضح نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي اليكساندر
نوفاك ان روسيا لم تعمل في ظل فرد حد اقصى
للسعر حتى لو اضطرت الى خفض الانتاج سلاحه
معاقبه مسك غير فعال بالنظر محليلين وبعض
اعضاء اوبك لان روسيا تبيع معظم نفقها الى
الصين والهند اللتين ترفضاني ادانه الحرب
في اوكرانيا ثم تتساؤل ممزوج بالخشيه يدور
بين الدول المصدره للنفط ماذا لو استخدم
الغرب في النهايه الاجراء نفسها ضد اي
منتج الحد الاقصى للسعر النفط الروسي كما
حدده حلفائك يبدو انه جعل مستوى الثقه بين
اوبك والغرب عند الحد الادنى هذه الايام
نقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا من ميلانو بيار
باولو ريموندي الباحث المختص في اقتصاديات
وسياسات الطاقه ومن موسكو السيد ايجور
يوشكوف المحاضر بالجامعه الماليه التابعه
للحكومه الروسيه وخبير صندوق امن الطاقه
الوطنيه مرحبا بكما سيد بيار باولو
ريموندي طبعا روسيا قللت من شان هذا
القرار ومن تاثيراته على اقتصادها ااه هل
توافق روسيا بهذا التقييم
فيديو اكشن
من الانتاج هي بحاجه الى ايجاد اسواق
جديده اليوم السوق الاوروبيه بدات تنغلق
امامها شيئا فشيئا وبالتالي روس بحاجه الى
ايجاد حلول
القرار هو ان ترى كيف ستتصرف الاسواق بعد
تحديد السقف وكذلك بالنظر الى الحاله
الاقتصاديه العالميه
روسيا لمواجهه هذا القرار خاصه ليست فقط
في تصدير النفط وانما في ايجاد
طريقه شحن بحريه لهذا النفط الروسي سواء
كان سيتوجه الى الى دول في الغرب او حتى
الى اسيا
راسي
كانت مستعده لهذه العقوبات خاصه بالنسبه
لتحديد سقف الاسعار
جهدت سفن الشحن للنفط تابعه لشركات روسيه
او اجنبيه
العهد بين الشركات الروسيه وغيرها شكلت
شكلت عفوا اسطول كبير مستعد
لان يعمل بعيدا عن العقوبات الامريكيه
والاوروبيه همم ولن يؤثر على اسعار النفط
المحمله في هذه الشاحنات ولدي روسيا نظام
تامين لهذه سفن الشحن همم
كل هذه السفن كانت امنت من شركات روسيه
مضمونه ولذلك روسيا
جهزت هذا الاسطول الضخم زائد نظام التامين
سوف يقوم الذبائن
الاسيويين بشراء النفط الروسي دون اي
سيطره اهم شيء هو نقل النفط الى الزبائن
وهذا ما تعمل عليه
روسيا وسوف نقوم بالالتفاف على العقوبات
هل الوضع بهذه السهوله يعني هل ستستطيع
فعلا روسيا ايجاد سوق بديله
ما تسوي
بهذه السهوله لانه هناك حاجه الى تشييد
بعض البناء تحتيه بالاضافه الى تنظيم
الامور ووضع اطار قانوني تشريعيه تنظيمي
وبالتالي سوف يكون امرا صعبا ولكن روسيا
امامها بعد الوقت حتى تتمكن من ايجاد
واعتماد
تدبيرهتين مثل
الهندسه تحديات هي سوف تتكبر
على اسعار النفط في العالم
القرار وحضرت اسطولا للشحن بحسب ما يقول
سيد اور طيب سيد اور همم على المدى الطويل
الى الى متى تستطيع روسيا ان تواجه هذا
الكم الكبير من العقوبات تحديد سقف
لسعر النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا ونذكر هنا
بان هذا القرار خاضع ايضا للمراجعه كل ما
ارتفعت ربما اسعار النفط سيلجا هذا
التحالف همم الجديد همم تقليل اسعار النفط
الروسي الى مدى الى اي مدى تستطيع روسيا
ان تصمد امام هذا القرارات
اسطوره
تتعود على هذه العقوبات وتتعامل معها في
مختلف المجالات نرى على طب المثال ان
القيود على ال ال
الفحم الروسي تعاملنا مع هذا من ذو فتره
طويله واوقفنا بيع
الفحم لاوروبا ونبيعه الاسيويه وهذا ما
يحدث مع الطاقه والنفط سوف نتحول الى
الاسواق الاسيويه الصين والهند وهمم جنوب
اسيا
الدول
الذين كانوا يشتروا من اوروبا سوف يتوقفوا
عن هذا لذلك هذا يحدث في ظروف قله همم
روسيا من الاصدار سوف ترتفع الاسعار في
الاسواق العالميه وعندها سوف تكسب روسيا
ما كانت تجنيه من
بيع النفط في الوقت السابق الدول الاسيويه
سوف تشتري الاسعار بالاسعار العلوي لذلك
روسيا تشعر بالراحه تماما الاتجاه هذه
الظروف شكرا لكما اجور يوشكوف في موسكو
وبير باولو ريموندي في ميلانو
هذا والقى قرار مجموعه السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي واستراليا بشان وضع سقف لسعر
النفط الروسيه المنقول بحرا بظلاله على
خيارات روسيا الممكنه ومدى تاثيره على
مداخلها النفطيه وبين من اعتبر ان اثار
القرار مساله وقت ومره بلا تاثير بدت
دهانات موسكو بالمقابل على اسواق بديله
اهمها السوق الاسيويه خصوصا الصين الهند
كيف سيكون رد موسكو على قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه الدول السبع واستراليا
وضع السقف لسعر النفسيه الروسيه المنقول
بحرا عند 60 دولارا للبرميل على قرارهم
قال مسؤولون روس في حين قال المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه ان موسكو تحتاج الى تحليل
الموقف قبل تجهيز رد لكنها لا تقبل وضع
سقف لسعر خانها تنتقد روسيا وتصفيه باعاده
تشكيل مبادئ السوق الحره وتبدو خيارتها في
تعزيز وجهات اخرى
الى الكره الاسيويه ارتفعت بنحو واحد 31%
على اساس سنويا في الاشهر الماضيه من هذا
العام
وهم المستفيدين من خصومه على مشتريتهم
اضافه الى تركيا على نحو 41% اجمالا من
صادرات النفط الروسيه عام 2022
وبينما يرى بعض المحللين ان كلا من
نيودلهي وبجن وانقر قد لا تقدم على زياده
احجام شحنه النفط من موسكو دون تخفيضات
اكبر للاسعار باعتبار الضرف فرصه [__]
لهم بدات تصريح وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سيرجي لابروفيست سباق لذلك حينما قال حين
الاهم ليس سقف السعر المقترح بالتفاوض
المباشر مع الشركاء لكن ثمه مشكله تتعلق
بالشحن مع تقلص المحتمل في حجم الاسطول
المتاح لنقل النفط الروسيه مع خساره السفن
الاوروبيه فعاده ما يستغرق شحن النفط
الخام البحر البلطيق الى الهند السفن ما
لا يقل عن اربعه اضعاف مده تسليم الشحنات
الى رتبان
الحجم نفسه سيتطلب اربعه اضعف عدد السفن
يقول محللون ان روسيا يمكنها ايضا ان تلجا
الى مخططات مثل نقل النفط من سفينه الى
اخرى لاخفاء اصولها وخلط نفطها بانواع
اخرى لالتفاف على الحظر اما الكسندر
نوفاكنه رئيس الوزراء الروسي فقال لن
نتعامل بموجب سقف اسعار النفط حتى ان
تطردنا الى خفض الانتاج خفضا قد تكون له
تابعه في سوق الطاقه العالميه فمحلل مصرف
دي انبي يرون ان هناك حاله كبيره من عدم
اليقين بشان تاثير المحتمل للاجراءات
الغربيه على المعروض الروسيه
للالتفاف على هذه التدابير باستخدام نفوذ
روسيا داخل اوبن كلاس مع التوقعاتهم
بانتعاش سعر النفط الخام فوق عتبه المئه
دولار للبرميل في الشهور المقبله
[موسيقى]
تابع مشان الايرانيه حيث اعلن المدعي
العام الايراني محمد جواد منتظري لو تم
وقفه عملي شرطه الاخلاق في هذه المرحله
وكانت شرطه الاخلاق قد اثارت نقاشا داخليا
في ايران بشان قانونيه عملها بعد وفاه
الشابه مهسا اميني في مخفر تابع لها في
سياق ذاته اكد منتظري ان البرلمان والمجلس
الاعلى للثوره الثقافيه يبحثان مساله
الحجاب وسيعللان نتائج مباحثتهما خلال
الاسبوعين المقبلين
كانت حديث الساعه في ايران بعد وفاه مهس
اميني في مخفر شرطه الاخلاق اليوم فيبدو
ان السلطه الاخلاقي تراجعوا حضورها على
الاقل حاليا
قرار قد لا يكون بسيطا او سهلا على اصحاب
القرار في الشرطه الايرانيه لكنه مهم في
توقيته بعد ان ارتفعت اصوات الاحتجاجات في
مدن الايرانيه عده
يخرج المدعي عام ايران محمد جعفر منتظري
ليعلن قرار وقف عمل شرطه الاخلاق حاليا في
ظل غياب موقف رسمي من الجهه المعنيه وهي
اداره الشرطه الايرانيه وهنا يبدو المشهد
اكثر وضوحا لغياب شرطه الاخلاق في شوارع
المدن فقد تراجع الى حد ما تقيد بعض
النسوه بالحجاب بشكل كامل وترجع معه الدور
الذي كانت تقوم به الشرطه حتى وقت قريب
فالمذكره الصادره عن المجلس الاعلى للثوره
الثقافي كانت حددت لها مهمه لمراقبه
السلوك العامه في المجتمع ضمن ما يعرف
بمدونه القواعد التنفيذيه لتعزيز العفه
والحجاب رجل في التقييد ببعض قوانين
الحجاب في الشارع يبدو انه ازعج الشق
حافظه في البلاد فارتفعت اصواته كذلك
مطالبه باتخاذ اجراءات لضبط الحجاب في
المجتمع لم تتاخر السلطه القضائيه لتعلن
ان نقاشا دائرا مع البرلماني والمجلس
الاعلى للثوره الثقافيه للتعامل مع ظاهره
عدم رعايه الحجاب
مساله الحجاب ان تكون القرارات وفق ثقافه
البلاد وعاداتها والا تتكرر المشكلات التي
كانت في السابق
تحرك في الشارع الايراني اذا يطالب
السلطات بتغييرات قد تكون جوهريه ومهمه
بالنسبه اليه اما السلطات فتحاول استيعاب
التطورات التي ظهرت بعد الاحتجاجات
تتحدث عن وعود للمحجين
[موسيقى]
ولا تغلق الشق الامنيه في تعاملها مع ما
تسميها اعمال الشغب وتتهم جهات خارجيه
بتوثير الاوضاع في ايران هو نقاش في
الداخل الايراني
وشرطه الاخلاقيه وقانونيه عملها والحجاب
وماذا الالتزام به قتلينا السلطات
الايرانيه في الاولى كما يرى الكثيرون هنا
لكنها قد لا تتراجعوا في الثانيه فمظهروا
الحجابي يشكل جزءا من هويه النظام في
ايران نردن تغيير الجزيره طهران
تنظم علينا الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي
الباحثه الاولى في مركز الجزيره للدراسات
والخبيره
دكتوره ماذا نفهم من القرار وقف عمل شرطه
الاخلاق محليا او محليا عفوا
هو كما قلت مرحله يعني هو استجابه مرحله
لحاله الضغط الاحتجاجي بشان هذه المساله
وهذه الحاله الاحتجاجيه ليست جديده في
ايران بشان الحجاب لكنها تاخذ اليوم بعدم
تصاعديا بمعنى ان هذه الحاله الاحتجاجيه
باتت تعبر عن ازمه اجتماعيه سياسيه في
ايران لذلك هذا التعامل
وان كان امراه حليق لا يحسم المساله ولا
يحسم ال- اا الجدل بشان الحجاب في ايران
وبالمناسبه هو جدلا قديم جدا حتى يعني
يسرق على الثوره الدستوريه باربعه عقود
بمعنى انه سواء كان في المرحله التي منع
فيها الحجاب او بالمرحله التي فرض فيها
الحجاب ومساله همم اشكاليه لكن همم
الخصوصيه او الميه ما يحدث اليوم انها
حلو بعدا احتجاجيا ضاغطا في ايران
اذا كان القرار لتهدئه الشارع كما تفضلت
هل من هل من المتوقع ان يستجيب الشارع
ويهدا فعلا لهكذا قرارات ولمناقشه فكره
الحجاب بحديداتها
همم لا اعتقد
بان في ايران لانه اذا كان الحاله
الاحتجاجيه المتعلقه بالحجاب هي واحده من
مظهرات هذه همم الازمه همم المقاربه
المطروحه بشان موضوع الحجاب من وجهه نظري
لم تحل ال- ال- همم المشكله همم لان
استمرار الحجاب فرض الحجاب في ايران لا
اظن ان هناك توجه للغاء فرض الحجاب هناك
نوع من الحل المتعلق بانهاء عمل همم شرطه
الارشاد او الشرطه التي كانت تراقب الحجاب
في الشوارع لكن ال- ال- فرض الحجاب بنص
القانون من وجهه نظري انه سيبقى اا قائم
لاكثر من سبب واحد من الاسباب ما اشار
اليه الزميل نور الدين بشان هويه هويه
الدوله في ايران المساله الاخرى ان هناك
كت قويه جدا في ايران تعارض همم مساله همم
الغاء القانون الذي يفرض الحجاب واي
ضا من ان هذا النقاش كان حتى في بدايات
نشاه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه فنجد مثلا ايه
الله تعليقان وهو من الرجال الاقوياء في
ايران كان معارضا لفرد الحجاب لكن الكتله
الاقوى استطاعت ان تفرض الحجاب بنص بنص
القانون هناك اكثر من ماده في القانون
تنظم مساله فرض الحجاب لذلك همم هذه
المساله تحتاج الى مقاربه قانونيه جريئه
جدا همم
الرساله التي ارادتها السلطات الايرانيه
همم دراسه مساله الحجاب والاعلان عن وقف
عمل شرطه الاخلاق محليه
اه تدرك هذا اقرار من ال من الحكومه
الحاليه ان هناك مشكله
وان هذه المشكله تحتاج الى حل وان كان هذا
الحل يعني اييي مرحله لان هذه الحكومه لا
تستطيع ان ااا تجري تعديلات على القانون
بهذه المساله الجذريه لذلك نجد ان شخصيه
مثل روحاني ذا الشخصيه قانونيه هو بالاساس
اا يدرك هذه المساله ويدرك صعوبه التغيير
لذلك هو طرح فكره الاستفتاء على موضوع
الحجاب بمعنى همم ان تلجا الدوله الى عمل
استفتاء عام همم يقرر الناس من خلاله ان
تبقى هذه القوانين او لا لذلك مجلس نجد
انه مجلس الابحاث التابعي لرئاسه
الجمهوريه سبق له وان اجرى مسح شاملا في
ايران بشان مساله الحجاب
النتائج التي وصلتني تقول بان هناك من 60
الى 80% من الايرانيين يعارضون الحجاب
الاجباري لكن هناك ايضا نسبه لا يستهان
بها ما زالت تجد انه ضروره الحجاب لكنها
تعارض فرضه بالقانون
الدراسات والخبيره في الشارع الايراني
شكرا لك
شرطه الاداب او شرطه الاخلاق في ايران هي
جهاز تاسس عام 2005 لمراقبه الالتزام
باللباس الاسلامي خاصه ارتداء النساء
للحجاب وينص القانون الساريه منذ عام
1983 على الزام النساء الايرانيات
والاجنبيات بارتداء الحجاب وملابس فضفاضه
في الاماكن العامه بصرف النظر عن ديانتهم
القوه التي تسمى ايضا دوريات الارشاد تضم
افراد شرطه من الرجال والنساء وتنتشر في
الاسواق والشوارع والساحات الرئيسيه
لمراقبه الالتزام بقانون اللباس توجه تلك
الدوريات انذارا للنساء المخالفات
وتطالبهن بتقديم تعهد حول الالتزام بقانون
الحجاب واحيانا يتم نقل النساء المخالفات
الى احد مراكز الارشاد والتوجيه التابعه
لشرطه الاخلاق حيث يتلق دروسا في كيفيه
ارتداء الملابس الاسلاميه هذا هو تعرض
الدوريات الارشاد لاتهامات وانتقادات بسبب
سوء التعامل مع وضع بعض النساء من خلال
التعرض لحرياتهن الشخصيه وفي اكتوبر
الماضي تعرضت شرطه الاخلاق لعقوبات من
بريطانيا بسبب ما اعتبرته قمعا للاحتجاجات
التي اندلعت في عقاب وفاه الشاب مهس اميني
بعد احتجازها من قبل شرطه
[موسيقى]
تتواصلوا الحفلات الانتخابيه في تونس وسط
دعوات من اغلب الاحزاب المعارضه لمقطعه
الانتخابات التشريعيه المقبله ووجهها
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وهو اكبر
منظمه عماليه انتقادات حاده للسلطات مؤكدا
انه لم يعد يقبل بالمسار السياسيه الحالي
بسبب التفرد بالحكم والغموض
يمضي الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد في تنفيذ
خريطه طريق ويزال يراها مخرجا للازمه
السياسيه التي تمر بها البلاد
مع اخترافي موعد الانتخابات التشريعيه
المقرره في السابع عشر من ديسمبر الحالي
تتصاعد المواقف السياسيه في تونس واخرها
التحرك والاحتجاجيه لجبهه الخلاص الوطني
المعارضه والتي اكدت ان ماوصلت اليه
الازمه الحاليه يجعل من رحيل رئيس قيس
سعيد اليوم امرا ضروريا لانقاذ البلاد
سبق هذا الموقف موقف لافط للاتحاد التونسي
للشغل الذي لم يكتفي بنقد المسار السياسي
الحالي بل اعلن رفضه له وفقدان الثقه به
ذا سيولدو نتائج لا احد يتوقع حجم اضافه
وما يستبطله من تفكك وتفتير
التبوبي لم يكتفي بذلك بل اشار الى الوضع
الذي تعيش فيه البلاد مؤكدا ان الاتحاد هو
القادر على مواجهه مشكلات تونس كما وجه
نقدا لاذعا للانتخابات التشريعيه المقبله
وفي اكثر من مناسبه انتقد الرئيس
الوطني
اليوم انهم يريدونه
خلاص وشعبه التونسيه هو الذي يريد الخلاص
منه
وفيما تشد حاله الاستقطاب بين الفرق
السياسيين تشد ايضا على الاقتصاديه
اجتماعيه من غلاء وبطاله وتدهور في
الاوضاع المعيشيه مظاهر الانقسام السياسي
في تونس اخذه في الاتساع مع اقتراب موعد
الانتخابات التشريعيه التي يرى المعارضون
انها لن تكون سوى امتداد للازمه الحاليه
في حين يؤكد سعيد ومؤيدوه انها ستؤسس
لاعاده عمل مؤسسات الدوله
وتحقيق الاستقرار السياسي سيف الدين
الجزيره تونس
حلبه الجزيره من مصادر محليه ان القوات
التركيه شنت غارات جويه جديده على مواقع
لما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في رفاعي
حلب والحسكه ترافق ذلك مع دعوه رجاء قائد
وما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم
عبدي لتدخل دوليه عمليه من اجل منع عمليه
ماليه جديده قد تبداها تركيا في الشمال
السوري
لم تبدا مناطق الشمال السوري منذ بدات
تركيا شنغهارات جويه على مواقع لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في العشرين من
نوفمبر الماضي
حددتها مصادر محليه للجزيره في منطقه شيوخ
تحتاني بمحيط مدينه عين العرب في ريف حلب
وقرى صيدا وتل طويل وتل اللبن والخالديه
والطريق الدولي بريفي الحسكه على الارض
نفذت قوات الدرك التركيه عمليات مداهمه في
منطقه جرابلس والباب الشماليه سوريا
واعتقل الثمانيه عشر شخصا قالت الداخليه
انهم ينتمون لتنظيمات ارهابيه وذكر بيان
للداخليه التركيه ان خمسه من المعتقلين
اعضاء في وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه وحزب
العمال الكردستاني وانهم كانوا ينشطون في
التجنيد وجمع المعلومات الامنيه
تطورات متلاحقه يتزايد معها قلق ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه رغم ترحيبها ببعض
المواقف الدوليه الرافضه لشن تركيا عمليه
بريه جديده ففي مقال نشرته صحيفه واشنطن
بوست قال قائد هذه القوات مظلوم عبدي انه
يتمنى ان تترجم هذه المواقف الدوليه الى
خطوات انهاء عمليات الجيش التركي ووجه
نداءه للولايات المتحده قائلا انهم فيما
تعرفوا بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه هم الحليف
الاكثر ولاء لامريكا في سوريا
اما انقره فلا تغيب عنها هذه المسائل
الاستغفار المجتمع الدولي من اجل معارضه
نشاطها العسكري الشماليه سوريا ما تفعله
التنظيمات الكرديه برايها هو انها تستخدم
تحالفها مع الولايات المتحده لاطفاء
الشرعيه على وجودها في المنطقه
او قوات النظام
يستخدمون تحالفهم معلومات المتحده لاخفاء
الشرعيه على وجودهم في شمال سوريا تسر
تركيا على ان كل مواقع التنظيمات الكرديه
في الشمال السوري ستظل اهداف المشروعه
لقواتها قريبه كانت من الحدود او بعيده
عنها من ذلك يظهر تصميم انقره على المضيق
قدما في خطتها لضمان الحزام الامني خلف
حدودها الجنوبيه بعمق 30 كم رغم استمرار
جهود الوساطه والمواقف الدوليه المنتقده
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بليكن
ان الولايات المتحده تدين اعمال العنف
التي تستهدف المدنيين في اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه واضاف بلانكن ان الضلعين في
اعمال العنف من الجانبين يجب ان يواجهوا
عداله متساويه
ولا يمكن ان يكون هناك اي مبرر لها مطلقا
ويجب محاسبه كل من يتورث فيها وكما قال
الرئيس ايضا سندينه ايضا اولئك الذين
يفشلون في ادانتي مثل هذه الهجمات والاسوء
من ذلك الذين يمتدحون او يكافئون
الارهابيين وعائلاتهم اننا قلقونا لان هذا
العام شهد مستويات اعلى بشكل كبير من
العنف في الضفه الغربيه من قبل
الفلسطينيين والمستوطنين الاسرائيليين على
حد سواء هذا العنف يجب ان يتوقف ومرتكبوه
يجب ان يواجه عداله متساويه
واضاف وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان بلاده
تدين التحرك الاسطاني الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه واضاف خلال كلمه له عفوا في مؤتمر
جيستري تدعم للسلام بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ان بلاده مستمره في دعمها
لحل الدوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى التوقع المخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيه استمرار تباطؤ وتيره القتال في
اوكرانيا لعده اشهر تصريح ياتي على عتاب
اشتداد قسوه الشتاء لكن ما الصعوبه هنا مع
اقتراب التراجع الحادي درجات الحراره
ستؤدي الوحوش والثلوج والبرد الى تعقيد
مهمه كل من القوات الاوكرانيه والجيش
الروسي في الاشهر المقبله فالجنود سيشعرون
بالبرد وسيكون من الصعب صيانه اسلحتهم
والياتهم لتبقى في حاله جيده وسيغطي الثلج
على الغام وهو ما يجعل اكتشافها صعبا هذا
لا يمنع امكانيه القتال لكنه بالتاكيد يحد
منه ويتوقع خبراء ان يتركز القتال حول
القرى بسبب الملاجئ التي تؤمنها القوات
التي تسيطر عليها تؤمن المعدات التي
يقدمها الحلفاء للقوات الاوكرانيه من
ملابس دافئه ومعدات خاصه بالبرد الشديد
لاوكرانيا تفوقا على روسيا التي تواجه
مشاكل لوجسيه منذ بدايه اصلا ووعدت كندا
بتقديم 500,000 قطعه من الملابس الشتويه
بما في ذلك سترات وسراويل واحذيه وقفازات
بينما تقوم لتوانيا بتجهيز 25,000 جنديا
اوكرانيا بالكامل لفصل الشتاء
تذكر بطبيعه الحال بان الحرب بدات في شباط
فبراير في منتصف الشتاء وبالتالي فان
المتحاربين لديهم خبره في هذا النوع من
القتال لكن ما الذي يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه
لاوكرانيا حتى اليوم الاحد مازال اكثر من
500 بلده اوكرانيه بدون كهرباء بعد
الضربات الروسيه التي الحقت اضرار كبيره
بشبكه الكهرباء كما ذكر مسؤول في وزاره
الداخليه الاوكرانيه في الاسابيع الاخيره
قصفت القوات الروسيه والحديث لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه اكثر من ثلثي منظومه
الطاقه التي توفر امدادات الكهرباء والماء
في انحاء اوكرانيا وتشن روسيا هجمات عنيفه
على البنيه التحتيه المخصصه لنقل الطاقه
والتدفئه في اوكرانيا بشكل اسبوعيه تقريبا
منذ اكتوبر تشرين الاول وهو ما ترك
الملايين دون تدفئه وسط درجات حراره دون
الصفر دفع ذلك الولايات المتحده لاعلان
تخصيص ثلاثه وخمسين مليون دولار اوكرانيا
لدعمي مشترياتي معدات شبكه الطاقه
وايصالها الى الدوله بشكل عاجل مع اجتياح
البردي مؤخرا وفي ظل الظلام الدامس وتراجع
درجات الحراره الى سالب خمس درجات مئويه
في بعض المناطق لجا الاوكرانيون الى
استخدام الشموع والمولدات التي تؤدي في
بعض الاحيان الى حرائق عربيه مميته لنفهم
اكثر الواقع في الاسابيع والاشهر ربما
المقبله علينا من لندن العقيد فيلم الخبير
العسكري واستراتيجي العقيد فيلب امام هذا
الواقع هل من الممكن تصور من سيستطيع ان
يصمد اكثر في فصل الشتاء المقبل
ولكم
اي من
الجيشين
افضل تجهيز عن واستعدادا
وتدريبا للتعامل مع المنطقه لقد راينا
الكثير من التقارير حول التجهيزات
والمعدات للجيش الروسي وما يصيده عفوا
كذلك من امدادات اما بالنسبه الى الجيش
الاوكراني
ولكن ايضا من الخارج كل جهه التي تساعد في
تدريب الجنود
الاوكرانيين مع اذن معدات شتويه كامله هي
ارض اوكرانيا وبالتالي اوكرانيا
الاوكرانيون
افضل من حيث الاستعداد للقتال في الشتاء
هذا الواقع ما الذي على الجبهات وعلى
الاستعدادات لمرحله مقبلهما
ليست بالضروره تجهيز وامداد الجنود ولكن
تاثير ذلك همم على ارض المعاركه
ضيفوا انا الارض رطبه وموحله كثيره اذا
بالنسبه الى
المصفحات فهي
مجهزه من اجل التعامل مع هذا الوضع ولكن
طبعا مع قيود راينا ذلك حين حاولت روسيا
ان تسيطر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه حيث
تعطلت الكثير من مركباتها اذا
الرطوبه والوحل كلها اذن او الوحوش
تصاعب عمل هذه المركبات الروسيه كذلك
روسيا في
نمطين دفاعي واوكرانيا هي في موقع الهجوم
وهي تختار الموقع الذي ستهجم فيه معظم
الاختطاليه حصل في الشمال الشرقي
بالقرب
ولكن
رؤوس في مكانهم واوكرانيا تدافع وروس
يحاولون منذ اسابيع على بال منذ اشهر
[موسيقى]
اختراقه وهم يحقون بعض المكاسب الصغيره
بضعه مئه الامطار
الثمن الذي يدفعونه كبير جدا
كما ذكرت اوكرانيا استعاده الكثير من
المناطق لا سيما في الجنوب في خرسان وايضا
في الشرق
مع هذه الصعوبات هل تتوقع همم تراجع
للقوات الاوكرانيه تقدم للقوات الروسيه
بالمقابل
الجيش الروسي من التقدم فهمم اوكرانيا او
جيش اوكرانيه
مضاد التالي ويستمر في الاعتداء على مراكز
التحكم والقياده الروسيه
بالمدفعيه
وصواريخ هاي مارس العاليه تطبيق التي
وفرتها الولايات المتحده بالاضافه الى
صواريخ وفرتها لها المانيا المملكه
المتحده ودع الاخرى وهذا يعاقب قدره روسيا
على تعزيز قدراته على المناوره من اجل
التصدي
لاوكرانيا اوكرانيا تمتلك المبادره الان
وهي سوف تحتفظ بها برايي وهذا سوف يقلقوا
الروس لانه اوكرانيا سوف تختار المكان
والزمان من اجل القيام بها هجمتها التاليه
طبعا الارض والميدان سوف يفرض ذلك
بالاضافه الى احوال الطقس ولكن طبعا
اوكرانيا هي التي تسيطره هنا سلاح الجو ما
جدرته في ظروف مماثله
بان قوات الجويه الاوكرانيه قامت بعمليه
دعم كبيره بالقرب من مواقع الروسيه اخر
اعتداءات صاروخيه منذ يومين على كيف انظمه
الدفاع الجوي التي وفرتها دواء الغربيه
ولكن
لما تملكه اوكرانيا قد انزلت كل صاروخ
اطلقته روسيا على كيف وهناك المزيد من
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الغربيه التي تصل
اوكرانيا وهذا من شانه همم يجعل من قدره
روسيا على الدرب جوا اقل فعاليه كذلك
لدينا مؤشرات بان روسي عباءات تنفذ لديها
الصواريخ المتطوره وهي مضره
على ازاله الرؤوس الحربيه من صواريخ نوويه
وشرائها عدد من الصواريخ الكانكازي من
ايران
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ومن لندن نتابع هذه الصور الاحتفاليه في
شوارع لندن للفوز منتخب انجلترا على منتخب
السنغال بثلاثه اهداف لصفر وتاهل منتخب
انجلترا
للدور ربع نهائي لمواجهه منتخب فرنسا الذي
فاز ايضا بدوره اليوم
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
واليكم تفكيرا باهم الانباء قبل الانتقال
الى الجوله الرياضيه المفصله يوميات
المونديال قال مسؤول بوزاره الداخليه
الاوكرانيه ان اكثر من 500 بلده اصبحت دون
كهرباء جراء القصف الروسي على شبكه
الكهرباء ومشاهده الطاقه في معظم
المقاطعات الاوكرانيه
وصلت معدات عسكريه امريكيه الى بولندا ضمن
برنامج لاعاده انتشار المعدات والقوات
القتاليه لحلف الناتو وتشكل المعدات جزءا
من حوالي 2000 و400 مركبه وصلت الى بولندا
واليونان الشهر الماضي من فرقه المشاهده
الاولى التابعه للجيش الامريكي
نقل موقع بلومبرج عن المبعوث الامريكي الى
ايران ان اداره الرئيس جو فايدن ستركز على
امدادات الاسلحه الايرانيه الى روسيا
حديثا يتزامن مع لقاء الروسي الايراني
عسكري في طهران جمع نائب وزير الدفاع
الروسي وقائد الاركان الايرانيه اللواء
ضمن اجتماع رابع اللجنه المشتركه للتعاون
العسكري
تبدا دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه اليوم الاثنين
العمل بسقف الاسعار الذي حددته دول مجموعه
السبع لشراء النفط الروسيه
دولارا للبرميل وسيحرم القرار وفق الاتحاد
الاوروبي موسكو من مصدر كبير من مصادر
دخلها لاستخدامها في تمويل حربها في
اوكرانيا
ولو حنائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه بخفض
انتاج النفط ردا على فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي
سقفا لسعر النفط الروسي وقال ان موسكو
ستضع اليات لمنع امداد النفط للبلدان التي
ستضع سقفا للاسعار
اعلن المدعي العام الايراني محمد جعفر
منتظري قرارا لوقف عمل منظومه شرطه
الاخلاق في المرحله الحاليه وقال منتظري
ان البرلمان والمجلس الاعلى للثوره يبحثان
مساله الحجاب
وقد اتهم وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
الولايات المتحده ودول الاخرى بتاجيج
الاحتجاجات للضغط على بلاده لتقديمه
تنازلات
[موسيقى]
الحصاد شكرا لكم على المتابعه بامان الله
ورعايته تابعوا الان يوميات الماضيه
[موسيقى]